and staying with politics presidential
hopeful Joe Biden is on the defensive
after reportedly miss telling a story on
the campaign trail about one soldier's
heroism Biden has been telling some
version of this story for years major
Garrett is in Washington he's been there
for years he's probably heard the story
major what does the former vice
president saying well good morning Biden
we should note is unapologetic telling
reporters that the essence of this story
about military bravery loss and guilt is
true but this is not about just another
Joe Biden gaffe it is about Biden
telling the story methodically and with
great passion but reportedly getting
almost every key detail wrong now truth
and the age of President Trump has taken
a beating but when it comes to military
stories precision matters in this case
Biden didn't have it this guy climbed
down a ravine carried this guy up on his
back under fire former Vice President
Joe Biden retold the story of a heroic
Navy captain during a campaign stop in
New Hampshire last week the general
wanted me to pin the Silver Star on him
I got up there and stand this that God's
truth my word as a Biden he stood his
attention I went to pin him I said sir I
don't want the damn thing do not put it
on me sir please sir do not do that he
died he died but according to the
Washington Post who spoke to more than a
dozen military and campaign sources
Biden got the time period the location
the heroic act the type of medal the
military branch and the rank of the
recipient as well as his own role in the
ceremony wrong Biden story appears to
have some truthful elements in 2011
Biden did award a medal to army staff
sergeant Chad workman after the soldier
tried to retrieve a dying comrade from a
burning vehicle workmen told the post he
felt Biden really understood his
situation but the soldier at the center
of Biden's searing campaign story
received the Medal of Honor from
President Obama in an interview Thursday
Biden called the criticisms ridiculous
saying the central point is it was
absolutely accurate what I said the
story was that he refused the medal
because the fella he tried to save and
risked his life saving died that's the
beginning middle and end if Biden were
to win his party's nomination he would
be running
against President Trump who the
Washington Post notes has made more than
12,000 false or misleading statements of
his own since he took office Biden has
made other blunders recently we choose
truth over facts poor kids are just as
bright and just as talons white kids
that in some quarters have provoked
questions about his age I say if they're
concerned don't vote for me
no one has accused Biden of lying or
exploiting military sacrifice for
Democratic voters Tony the question may
be is this a sign that more that Biden's
memory is at fault or just that his
facts are wrong but his passion is right
and major before I let you go another
major shake-up at the White House
yesterday the president's personal
assistant Madeleine West or Howard
unexpectedly resigned yesterday what
happened she's head of Oval Office
operations which means she's very close
to the president proximity wise and
within the White House staff she hears a
lot President Trump runs a very high
volume presidency and what you hear when
you're that close to the president
should be kept discreetly within the
West Wing recently we've been told that
wasn't true that was described by many
White House officials as an act of
disloyalty and therefore she's out all
right major thank you very much